j'accueille rachid taha
où
et
dif est là le petit arbuste a comme
alain moi j'en portais en parler de bain
de minuit à l'instant non pas c'est lui
je présentais l'émission avec un petit
tarbouche le look farouk et tu sais qui
avait commencé c'était croûte chez way
qui lui aussi cool a chuté bah oui c'est
vrai t'as raison philippe rocher si tu
nous regardes ouais c'est une façon de
représenter la turquie
selon pure tourments ça va oui alors je
sais pas si vous connaissez la chute à
mais pour ceux qui le connaissent pas
didier
je
mon bilan
comment
ouah
fourni
m
autorise
chien
et puis ça
bah
là
scheer
proche de casbah c'est sur le bab
l'andam le résultat à saint pie x la
hotte de cache-ballon